we have sunk to this we can now rank the
30 craziest things done by one
presidential candidate just in the
debates just in two of the debates we
have the 30 craziest things by Donald
Trump even leaving out the apology for
they grabbed them by the [ __ ] tape the
apology in which the first half of the
first sentence was I've never said I'm a
perfect person which was a lie because
he once tweeted I consider myself to
perfect and have no faults the apology
in which the second half of the first
sentence was nor pretended to be someone
that I'm not when he used to pretend to
be his own press spokesman named John
Barron and John Miller and didn't even
change his voice while he pretended to
be with being somewhat he was not we're
leaving those out and many many more
here's our list number 30 from Sunday
night ice just endorsed me first it
sounded like he said Isis just endorsed
me secondly ice is a branch of the
government involved in immigration it
cannot endorse anybody he met either the
union representing employees of ice or
he meant vanilla ice number 29 in the
first debate he brought up Rosie
O'Donnell and said I said very tough
things to her and I think everybody
would agree that she deserves it and
nobody feels sorry for her what are you
nine number 28 in the first debate he
claimed the DNC hackers believed by the
government to be Russian quote could be
someone sitting on the bed that weighs
400 pounds okay number 27 Sunday night
same topic he said maybe there is no
hacking number 26 also debate too
without apologizing for crapping all
over his parents insisted that if he had
been president then captain Khan would
be alive today because unlike her who
voted for a war without knowing what she
was doing I would not have had our
people in Iraq number 25 first debate he
denied there is a 2002 tape of him
supporting the invasion of Iraq wrong
then Hillary Clinton said that is
absolutely proved over and over again he
replied wrong wrong number 24 second
debate she said his claim that he did
not say what is on the tape had been
debunked his replies has not been
debunked that has not been debunked
and has not been debunked number 23
first debate he offered proof that he
was against the Iraq war by saying
people should call Sean Hannity because
he told him he mentioned Hannity by name
eight times in a presidential debate a
debate that he was trying to win number
22 Sunday night about terrorism quote
you know there's always a reason for
everything
well you've got me there number 21 first
debate denied he had ever said global
warming was a Chinese hoax quote I did
not I did not I do not say that no he
only tweeted it number 20 debate two she
also sent a tweet out at three o'clock
in the morning but I won't even mention
that you just mentioned it number
nineteen first debate explaining when he
settled government prosecution for
racial discrimination and renting
apartments there was quote no admission
of guilt number eighteen first debate
she noted he rooted for the 2008 housing
collapse quote he said that's called
business by the way number seventeen
first debate admitting he paid low or no
taxes quote that makes me smart number
sixteen first debate then said if he had
paid more tax quote it would have been
squandered to number fifteen first
debate she mentioned his father got him
fourteen million dollars and he called
it a quote small loan number fourteen
Sunday complained to the moderator I'd
like to know Anderson why aren't you
bringing up the emails when they had
just finished a question about the
emails number thirteen also debate
number two claimed truthfulness was
quote the big difference between Abraham
Lincoln and you that's a big big
difference we're talking about some
difference number twelve Sunday again
lied about the 2008 Clinton campaign
starting birtherism number eleven first
debate asked what he had to say to
people of color about his birth tourism
quote I say nothing I say nothing number
ten Sunday asked by a Muslim American
for help with the rising Islamophobia in
this country he told her to inform on
her fellow Muslims
then lied quotes in San Bernardino many
people saw the bombs all over the
apartment number nine first debate
insisted he could not release his tax
returns then immediately said he would
release them quote when she releases her
33,000 emails that have been deleted
number eight Sunday asking why in the
Senate Clinton had not repealed carried
interest and getting the answer from her
that there was a Republican president
then he seemed not to know what that
meant
quote if you an effective senator you
could have done it if you were an
effective senator you could have done it
but you were not an effective senator
number seven first debate claimed he had
a better temperament than Clinton while
clearly showing he had no idea what the
word temperament means quote I think my
strongest asset may be by far is my
temperament I have a winning temperament
I know how to win and then number six
Sunday twice threatened Clinton with a
special prosecutor said quote you'd be
put in jail and you'd be in jail number
five Sunday asked why he had tweeted
about Alicia Machado check out sex tape
he said quote no there wasn't check out
a sex tape when he tweeted check out sex
tape number four sunday asked about the
other one they grabbed them by the [ __ ]
sex tape said it was locker room talked
five times locker room talk because all
locker rooms featured two men wearing
microphones in a bus while they know
they are being videotaped for a
television show
number three Sunday pivoted from the
tape which by itself cost him the
support of at least 17 elected
Republicans by saying certainly I'm not
proud of it but this is locker room
talked you know when we have a world
where you have Isis chopping off heads
he segwayed from grabbed them by the
[ __ ] to chop off their heads
number two Sunday said quote sniff their
sniff after doing it throughout the
first debate he sniffed at least eighty
sniff times and sniffed the second sniff
debate sniff alone he was so loud he was
just this side of thirth
later eighty times at just over ninety
minutes that's one time every 68 seconds
what's with the goddamn snipping by a
handkerchief see your doctor dr. fini
boombots and the number one craziest
thing yet by Trump in the debates
how could he have not known this how
could somebody have not seen this how
could somebody have not stopped this in
a debate the whole point of which was to
change the narrative from the grab them
by the [ __ ] tape do you know what they
call the shirt that his wife Melania
wore to the debate it's a [ __ ] bow
shirt that's what it's called by the
designer Gucci a [ __ ] bows silk crepe
dashing shirt [ __ ] bow the woman wore a
[ __ ] bow to the event at which her
husband was trying to get people to stop
thinking about [ __ ] and of all this
[ __ ] is not bad enough
worst of all worst of all this sniffling
sniffling pacing threatening preening
bullying nitwit and would-be dictator
made it necessary for me to find out
what a [ __ ] beau silk crepe de Sheen
shirt is that's the closer on Keith
Olbermann watch this space